: - joins us tonight Colton thanks
coming up absolutely thank you guys so
much for having me before we get into
anything I just want to UM make sure
that everybody hasn't forgotten why we
are actually here tonight I mean we lost
17 lives last weekend yes I actually
physically put to it arrest and to me
that was the hardest thing in the world
to endure I mean nobody should have to
go through this so as long as we're
taking the right steps to move forward
from this and make sure that this
doesn't happen again I'm all for that
well we certainly haven't forgotten
thank you for reminding us yet again and
we think that the only way to make the
country better and maybe put a dent in
this scourge is to have a rational
thoughtful conversation about what to do
next and with that in mind you were
planning to go to this event listen and
tell me if I miss characterizing any of
this and you said in a settlor what
you're at the request of CNN producer
you sent in a number of questions of
statements you wanted to make questions
that you wanted to ask of the
politicians on the stage and they
rewrote one of your questions is that
right yes sir so what did what had
happened was is the four days ago I had
gotten contacted by a lady named Kerry
Stevenson from CNN she um had asked me
to originally just write a speech it was
going to be at the town hall at the BB&T
center so I agreed I felt like it would
be the right thing to do be able to go
speak my part as well as open eyes to a
few things that I thought that could
make this situation a little better from
there three days ago so the next day
after that we had gotten I got an email
back from her and she asked for more of
questions rather than a speech which I
was totally fine with so I wrote Liz
less of a speech and more of questions
that I wanted to ask at the Town Hall
the day after that it was more of just
questions she asked for just questions
that I would like to ask so I gave her
my questions and then yesterday at about
5:15 I made contact with her and she had
asked if I just asked her one question
so what they had actually done was wrote
out a question for me because in my
interview with CNN I talked about arming
the teachers if they were willing to arm
themselves in the school to carry on
campus
and they had she had taken that of what
I had briefed on and actually wrote that
question out for me so I have that
question here if you'd like me to ask it
for you well but I just want to make
sure I have this straight so you sent
them a long in effect essay on what you
thought but they did they put his own
words in the question and they weren't
the same as the words you would send and
they were the producers words absolutely
they had taken what I had wrote and what
I had briefed on and talked about and
they actually wrote the question for me
but but not with your words I mean they
put their own words into your question
even after after they'd asked you to
send questions in but that seems
dishonest on it definitely did and
that's kind of why I didn't go last
night originally I had thought that it
was going to be more of my own
questioning in my own say and then it
turned out to be more of just a script
and she had actually said that over the
phone that I needed to stick to the
script that's that's remarkable what did
you watch last night I watched a little
bit of it I kind of felt like I didn't
really need to because I know that as
soon as that at what had happened with
me that I was going to be more scripted
and wasn't actually going to be actually
actual questions then I didn't feel the
need to fully watch it so if CNN was
willing to reword your question put
their own words in your mouth and as you
said you didn't want to go along with
that do you think they did that to other
people last night I mean absolutely from
what I did see I had seen a couple
people that had asked questions before I
did leave my house and it was a little
piece of paper cut out and I know for a
fact that nobody cut their own paper out
and wrote their own question especially
when they were all based off the same
topic so to me it from right there it
showed that this isn't correct why are
they all have the same size piece of
paper with a short little question on it
so I guess what a total what's
surprising is yours I mean you're not
just some person off the street you're a
survivor of this she
and the point was to listen to you to
the survivors of the shooting were you
surprised by the way they behaved I mean
it honestly it was very shocking to me
because we just went through such a
horrific tragedy for them to take that
and now make such a big news brass cast
over what they want to hear it was very
upsetting to me it's shocking to us to
trust me
in the actual journalism business Colten
thank you thank you for telling us that
it's really interesting appreciate
absolutely